ils sont jeunes et le partage plusieurs
priorités sont devenus tous deux maires
hier soir je reçois catherine fournier
nouvelle mairesse de longueuil et ses
fans voyez nouveau maire de laval
bonsoir et félicitations vous deux
bonsoir merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
monsieur voyez vous avez 33 ans le plus
jeune maire de l'histoire de laval
madame fourni vous êtes à plus jeune
mairesse au sujet parce que l'histoire
de l'orgueil vous faites partis tous les
deux de ce vin changements qu'on a
observés dans plusieurs grandes villes à
laval concrètement monsieur boyer le
vous allez changer quoi comment à quelle
vitesse oui mais c'est certain que moi
j'ai participé aux prises des décisions
et dernières années donc je souhaite
poursuivre dans les grandes orientations
qu'on a appris que ce soit en matière de
développement économique d'une
protection d'environnement ou autres et
dont les orientations votées les mains
mais pas vraiment la façon de faire la
politique va être différente et
évidemment j'ai une personnalité qui est
différente de celle de monsieur demers
je souhaite laval où va le monde la
vague qui va être audacieux qui va
prendre des risques dès fois qu'ils vont
vous faire des choses d'abord tu es donc
par exemple concret pour nous là qu'est
ce que vous pourriez faire de
différentes monsieur demers condamné
votre style avoue une
belle part à manger là bas on l'a
souvent vu comme une ville un peu de
banlieue je crois que de moins en moins
le cas et je souhaite que notre déçoit
vraiment ouverte sur le monde donc je
souhaite vraiment à forger des
partenariats aller à l'étranger
tenir des éléments internationaux sur
nos territoires pour moi c'est important
on est une ville où c'est qu'ils
versaient que tu as mal à moitié notre
population était sur l'immigration donc
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on a fait
beaucoup dans les années à laval mais
que je souhaite mettre plusieurs avant
et aussi la place des jeunes à laval
présentement beaucoup de nos jeunes dans
les 18 35 ans à montbard orient pour les
études des femmes et des enfants mais
chouette quand la mariée plus de traits
culturels artistiques avoir plus
d'activités à offrir aux jeunes pour les
garder sur nos territoires madame
fournier alors je ne me reste mais quand
même une politicienne d'expérience vous
étiez jusqu'à tout récemment député
provincial d'ailleurs il ya un poste qui
vient s'ouvrir il va avoir une élection
partielle vous vous voyez longue et
comme l'a si vous le premier changement
à faire votre grande priorité un peu
dans l'urgence c'est quoi c'est quoi la
marque la catherine fournier pour
longueuil
c'est la collaboration
on a connu tellement de crédit cit et le
conseil de ville et je pense que ce que
les gens soient vides massivement me
faire confiance à mon équipe et moi
lorsque singulière et c'est parce qu'on
voulait tourner la page sur ses amis est
entré dans un nouveau chapitre une ère
de collaboration où on va s'élever
autour des joutes partisanes pour
travailler pour le bien commun pour
travailler pour améliorer le bien-être
de la population donc juste dans le
changement de ton dans le développement
également d'une culture de transparence
à l'hôtel de ville il va y avoir un
changement assez radical une nouvelle
grande priorité c'est contribuer à
rebâtir et à accroître la confiance
veillez longueillois des longueuillois
envers leurs vestons démocratique qui
aligne au
coeur
pendant la campagne électorale vous
comme candidat chacun de votre côté vous
vous êtes rejoint vous avez formé une
alliance vous trouviez que il faut
proposer un plan d'action pour la crise
du logement c'est l'enjeu de votre
génération avec les changements
climatiques bien entendu concrètement le
cet aliment cela va se concrétiser
comment dans les prochaines semaines de
madame fournier
met la barre et j'ai très hâte d'obtenir
une première rencontre officielle avec
stéphane ce tir le sujet qu'on avait
annoncé il ya quelques semaines que nous
allons être les instigateurs d'un sommet
en québécois où on veut prendre le
leadership de la recherche de solutions
à la crise du logement donc autant sur
les marchés le captif car la surchauffe
sur le marché immobilier donc pour
trouver des solutions innovantes pour
cbo on s'entend ce tifo seulement une
municipalité qui peut avoir les réponses
appropriées s'apprendre concertation les
différents partenaires de la société
civile du secteur privé mais également
des différents paris gouvernement parce
que l'habitation c'est une compétence
qui est partagé avec québec avec le
fédéral donc c'est de réunir tout le
monde autour de la table pour justement
identifier des solutions par exemple
d'aider à proprement québécoise on ne
parlait d utilité sociale ou également
les les exemples internationaux qu'on va
paris à berlin achète une partie du parc
immobilier mais pour ça il faut qu'on
mette sur la table mais pouvoir les
ressources dont dispose à lille viennent
donc c'est pourquoi est important
également la forme est votre part les
gouvernements autour de la table
monsieur boyer comme ça à paris cet
enjeu là vous avez dit importants qui
ont changé les règles parce qu'en ce
moment les règles joue pas en faveur des
jeunes jouent pas en faveur de tous les
gens qui qui ont quand même une petite
économie mais qui arrive plus à payer
les logements ou les haies les maisons
aujourd'hui ça va prendre un bon rapport
de force avec le gouvernement les
différents paliers gouvernement là
dedans
c'est votre beau temps le cbot
génération si c'est le moment de faire
votre marque on entendait monsieur
fernandez jeu savant dans notre panel
municipal qui disait c'est tellement
important de faire sa marque rapidement
ne pas attendre jusqu'à quel point vous
allez tenté de l'exercer ce rapport de
force ce soit par des alliances ou par
votre attitude je sais pas pour réussir
à faire votre marque tout de suite mais
en fait je pense que c'est un homme
c'est pas un enjeu qui litigieux dans ce
sens qu'on a tous intérêt à régler ces
problèmes là on est vue d une inflation
des prix de 20 à 30% de l'habitation en
fin d'année donc je crois que tout le
monde est conscient aujourd'hui de
l'importance donc à mon avis la
collaboration va être plutôt facile et
justement cette collaboration là c'est
ce qu'on ne souhaitait incarner dans le
camp des campagnes électorales de dire
de la campagne on est capables de
travailler ensemble souvent parce que
j'ai vu c'est quand même huit ans que
conseil municipal parfois une dispute
est temps de tirer la couverte de leur
côté elles pour avoir les fonds qataris
dans leurs disparités mais des enjeux
comme l'habitation l'environnement ça
s'arrête pas de frontières
administratives donc c'est important de
laisser cette dynamique là justement
réceptive et la courtepointe et de voir
ensemble qu'est ce qu'on peut mettre de
l'avant pour moi le cerveau du crack et
surtout amateur l'habitation selon lui
qui est complexe donc cette solution est
là dedans c'est que ça touche ok
municipalité il ya moyen de faire bloc
là dedans madame fournier je reviens
encore un autre panel la municipale
juste avant parce qu'on avait des élus
d'expérience qui se prononcer sur sur
votre nouvelle génération et qui disait
il reste peut-être d'être déçu dans les
faits parce que la vraie ville elle est
vraiment difficile et monsieur fernandez
dans les fêtes les grands enjeux par
exemple transition environnement les
changements l'ex en vienne qui vont être
vraiment quelque chose s'il vraiment
défis de votre génération si dans les
faits les villes on pense pouvoir là
elles ont absolument besoin du
gouvernement du québec du gouvernement
d'ottawa aussi du canada est ce que est
ce que vous pensez être capable d'aller
chercher des pouvoirs ou d'autres utile
de changer finalement témoigner il ya
donc un avant goût qui ont essayé qui
sont cassé les dents le dessus
effectivement je pense que c'est un
travail important je pensais comme le
défendent en battant le rapport de force
tic sont bas de plus en plus de villes
s'allier en prêt elle mais je pense que
c'est comme ça qu'on puisse avoir un
levier important aux cris différents
paliers de gouvernement donc c'est sûr
qu'il ya par exemple dans le cadre de
notre série sur l'habitation c'est
qu'elles sont là vont devoir retraités
vous avez raison elle est venue ils sont
assez limitées au québec dans leur
pouvoir dans leurs ressources donc c'est
sûr que ce sera l'éléphant dans la pièce
mais en même temps moi je suis confiante
que les choses que les projets vont
pouvoir bien avancé également longuet
avec mon expérience et comme député des
cinq dernières années je m'explose
connaissance des leviers qui s'offrent à
la ville de longues et c'est également
un travail de collaboration en d'aller
justement être travaillés tendent la
main au gouvernement fédéral moi le fait
de travailler qu'ils n'ont pas les
gouvernements elle ça me fait pas peur
au contraire je pense que justement il
faut
qu'on garde je pense que ça fait quoi de
sa dernière chose sur le taux de
participation
très bas dans les deux cas la route en
longueuil qu'à laval on va voir des
chefs d'ailleurs monsieur boyer je
pourrai seul un rapport de force
conservons les gens derrière soient vous
êtes jeune vous allez représenter les
jeunes familles les jeunes que jeunes
que vous aussi on a l'impression qu'ils
viennent pas voter on a l'impression ces
affaires ne les intéresse pas un mot
là-dessus
web en fait je crois que c'est une crise
démocratique qu'on vit au québec nomme
en général les faits qu'une élection
fédérale juste avant l'élection
municipale a probablement aidé on
sentait une certaine lassitude sur le
terrain pour les élections l'apport des
citoyens mais sur l'étendue même si
c'est pas d'ensemble des citoyens qui
vont voter je pense que ça n'empêche pas
que faut continuer pas pour régler les
enjeux et
donc on va définissent mandat voir se
creuser les méninges à trouver des
solutions je crois qu'à laval et
longueuil on a des réalités
particulières du fait que beaucoup de
grands médias sont basés à montréal par
ce qui se passe dans le temps des
couronnes et pourtant il ya un temps
important de la profession qui vivent
ici on veut des citoyens qui sont
impliqués qui vont en beauté qui
prennent qu'un goût à leur vie doit
savoir ce qui se passe dans leur
viennent donc enfin retrouver aussi
comment est pour communiquer mieux les
formations s'étaient on entend le
message on vous inviter plus souvent
tous les deux
mais bon on souhaite beaucoup de courage
de force détermination pour passer au
travers de vos mandats il ya des gros
défis sur la table bercy fait une
station encore
merci à vous au revoir